my counsel uh will be stricken from the
record it was an improper question that
he asked
well please don't consider it in any way
the witness's state of mind is not an
issue in this case
this the barozone state of mind is an
issue not the witnesses so please ignore
that question it was improper and it's
stricken from the record
all right let's call the witness back in
just watching
you may have a seat miss osborne
all right council i have no further
questions of miss osborne at this time
any cross-examination briefly judge
ms osborne good morning good morning
have you ever testified in court before
no all right
uh is your mother lara osborne yes
what's the nature of her relationship
with michael barason at this point i'm
there in a romantic relationship
hold on is there an objection counsel i
objected to relevance
this clearly goes towards bias this was
explored on cross-examination with state
witnesses
overworld
i'm sorry there was an objection could
you just tell the jury again what your
last answer was they're in a romantic
relationship thank you no further
questions josh
thank you
you swore under oath to tell the truth
when you brought here this morning yes
would you violate that oath simply
because of a relationship your mother
was having absolutely not thank you no
further questions oh you may step down
man thank you
your next witness the defense calls mary
defranco
mary defranco
just watch her step
please remain standing for a moment
place your left hand on the bible raise
your right hand listen to the oath
please please join the presence of
almighty god that the testimony
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth yes please state your name mr last
name for the record mary defranco
d-e-f-r-a-n-c-o thank you all right you
can have a seat matt please keep your
voice up nice and loud so all the jurors
can hear your answers that microphone
does not
project your voice and only records it
okay all right very good if you don't
understand the question please indicate
that i'll have counsel rephrase go ahead
counsel
um miss defranco uh do you live in
illinois i do
what town crystal lake
um
what is your educational background
i have a bachelor's degree in finance
and a master's in finance and economics
so a bachelor's degree and a master's
yes
uh
what do you do for a living
i'm in data and intelligence services i
do data standardization for a large
financial institution
and you do that in illinois i do
uh do you pursue any um hobbies related
to the horse world i do
what hobbies do you pursue i'm an
amateur enthusiast um for dressage
how long have you been pursuing that
um dressage probably the last 10 years
but i was doing 100 jumper sports before
that so all in all about 25 years
and in connection with your pursuit of
that have you
taken any lessons or training over the
years yes
tell us about that
um so i have taken dressage lessons on a
regular basis um i have my horse in
training as well as myself
so i probably take um
three lessons a week and then ride
independently twice a week
and over how long of a time period have
you been pursuing training
10 years
um you mentioned your horse are you also
a horse owner yes i am and over your
association with this hobby how many
times how many horses have you owned
oh my over the years or currently over
the years over the years
over a dozen over a dozen um
is your daughter also involved in in any
way in the horse world yes she is what's
her involvement she is also a dressage
writer
um she rides as a professional
oh she's a professional okay
and um
uh
let's go back to uh
well let me ask you this first um
do you know michael barrison i do
how long have you known him since 2016.
so almost four years i'm sorry since
2016. so six years almost
and in what capacity did you become
introduced to michael barrison my
daughter was interested in training with
him in the summer of 2016 after the
olympics
and she contacted him
and that's how we met
was her interests at all
inspired by what happened in the rio
olympics that year of
course and so did your daughter come to
uh
start working with michael yes she did
and did you also over the years work
with michael yes i came frequently for
to both to visit my daughter and then um
most recently take lessons as well okay
and so um
the fact that you took lessons with
michael is that the only capacity in
which you knew him when you were
actually in the arena taking lessons or
did you come to know him in other
contexts i consider michael a friend
and how long have you considered michael
to be your friend since i've met him
okay
now
did your daughter become employed at
michael's barn
she did um when we
when she came to um
michael's in 2016 she was a client
and she was a client through
that
2016-20
season in florida
and it was in the spring of 2017 that
she became
a working student for michael
and um
as a working student did she live at the
farm she did
was she living at the farm in the summer
of 2019 yes
and did she board her her horse there
yes did she have more than one horse
there yes she did how many she had two
uh and
did there come a time in 2019
when you uh made a new acquisition with
with respect to your hobby i did i
bought a new horse a young one in the in
june of 2019.
and um uh
was that horse brought by you or on your
behalf to michael's farm yes i had my
horse shipped to michael's farm um in
the middle of july july 15 16 something
like that of 2019. and why did you have
your horse shipped there for training
okay
so uh is training of the horse separate
from training of the rider sometimes um
my horse was four so he was a baby and
uh i'm an amateur older lady adult and i
shipped him there to start his training
and uh so that he would become more
confident and safe for me
based on on your understanding of how
the farm operated at that time in june
of 2019
was there a person who was
specifically assigned to train young
horses
not to my knowledge um
did you know an individual there named
mike mcgrane yes
and what was his role at the farm if you
know oh yes so mike actually rode
very young horses so horses that were
not accustomed to even having a saddle
on them yet um they were they were very
untrained so
my horse was a little further along than
that so the horse that you purchased as
a four-year-old wasn't going to be
trained by mr mcgrane no
who was training your horse at that time
my daughter's father my daughter your
daughter was okay and when it came to to
uh
your training uh in the summer of 2019
did you have a regular schedules when
you come to new jersey
yes
the plan was for me to be in new jersey
two weeks out of every month
i would come
during those two weeks ride and train on
my horse and then go back to illinois
for two weeks and while i was gone um
the horse would be in training
and uh
who was training you and your horse at
michael's farm that summer
um i took a couple lessons from michael
i took a couple lessons from justin
and
how did you
have any impression of the quality of
training you were receiving from justin
for example it was excellent
no complaints none
did there come a time in july of 2019
when you made one of those
two-week visits
yes
and do you recall the precise date you
arrived and when you were supposed to
leave
um
precisely arrival no um i would have
arrived somewhere around the 15th or the
16th
and i was scheduled to leave though on
the 31st
okay so you came to the farm in july
matter about that time period
and
is there anything in particular you
observed at the farm at that time
it was
not as happy a place as it used to be
okay and could you be a little more
descriptive as to what indicated to you
that it wasn't as happy and of a place
as it used to be
it there was a lot of tension in the air
it was very stressful
the
michael's demeanor was
not as
it used to be not as engaging he was he
was elsewhere in his mind
um
there were
other borders who were
definitely
you know also
tense and
um lots of conversation around
the
just the feeling in in the barn that it
just wasn't right
did you make any observations about your
daughter at that time when you came to
the farm and noticed that things weren't
right
she was equally tons if not more i
actually was very concerned about her
when i arrived what concerns did you
have about your daughter specifically
with respect to what was going on at the
farm at that time i think
when i arrived if i remember correctly
she was very concerned
about the horses
about the safety
of the horses she was concerned that
the schedule was getting very disruptive
in the barn because of
just
just the the cadence of things in the
barn you know my daughter worked there
so in the morning there's there's
feeding and then there's watering and
then there's turnout but because of all
the all the tension and the chaos that
was going on at the time
that it all had been up ended and so she
was quite stressed out about all that
well you had your new four-year-old
there yeah correct
did you have any concerns with respect
to your new horse
um at at first i was i thought no
everything's fine and then within a few
days i could tell that things weren't
going well um the again the tension at
the barn was too high i started having
concerns about safety myself both for
myself and my daughter as well as the
horses
when you say you had concerns about
safety
what specifically were your concerns
well there was some the the tension that
was going on was because that there was
a client there
um that was being problematic
and um menacing and harassing um to to
michael mary haskins
and i believe even justin
and it got to the point that that was
bleeding over
into the the culture of the barn as well
as
into the the process of taking care of
the horses so i was worried that you
know
something was going to happen to them in
the middle of the night or
you know when i when we weren't there
so
it was just
not a pleasant place to be
as a result of what you observed what
your concerns were and what you were
experiencing
did you start making any plans with
respect to where to board your horse and
your daughter's horses
oh absolutely so as the days continued
during my visit
um my daughter and i discussed that you
know we needed to move the horses
we needed to get out of that environment
it was too menacing and harassing i
wasn't happy and i was just as disturbed
i think as everyone else about what was
happening there
luckily
the barn is located in an area where you
can drive you know 15 minutes in any
direction and there's there's lots of
horse farms
so we were looking for you know safe and
clean and just just to get out of what i
was perceiving to be a um
not so safe environment
as a result of your presence
at the facility
were you familiar with the locker area
of the barn yes of course okay
i'm going to show you what was marked
for identification as 800-42
you have before you a photograph uh
does this well what is it a photograph
of so this is the locker area as you
step the white door um represents the
door that would lead into the club room
so if you were walking out of the club
room and stepping down those few steps
you'd be in the in the locker area where
boarders would have their personal items
uh based upon your personal observations
at the at the farm does this picture
accurately depict the layout of the
lockers and the walls at the time yes
i move
800-42 in evidence
no objection judge what
800-42 defense exhibit is admitted into
evidence
based upon your uh
well you were physically in this space
correct
on a number of occasions yes on a
regular basis yes
okay uh was there a bench there
here in this in this area yeah
i'm sorry i don't know if your answer
was no i'm sorry no there was no bench
so you're looking at a photograph where
the lockers are and you're saying that
there's no bench in that area when
you're counsel
you don't need to repeat the answer okay
every question all right the jury hears
it i'm certain
so just ask your follow-up question
please i will
um
did you have um and i don't want you to
talk about the words that were spoken
okay but did you have private
conversations
uh with michael barissone
or other people at the farm
about the tensions that you were
observing yes
and
did you have those private conversations
in a particular location
multiple locations
uh did you ever have conversations like
that
um
in the office yes
did you ever have conversations like
that in the club room yes
did there come a time when you developed
a concern
that someone was listening to those
private conversations that wasn't
present participating in them yes
and
when did you develop that concern with
respect to what was happening at the
farm
when my own words verbatim were repeated
by someone who would not have been there
and
posted in social media
do you recall
without saying what the words were do
you recall where you were
physically when you spoke those words
michael's office okay and who was
present when you spoke those words mary
haskins anyone else no
how far is the office from the locker
area if you recall
has to be 100 feet
and did you then
i'm sorry did you say that you your
words were posted on social media yes
who posted them lauren kanrick
when you were there
from the period of well you were there
from the period of july 31st through the
time the incident occurred correct yes
and in fact you were there the day of
the incident yes and you were
interviewed by the police and and other
people after the incident yes okay
were you
present when police were called
to the farm before the incident yes
did you
observe
michael barissone in the days leading up
to the incident yes
uh at that point in time how many years
had you known him
three
did you see
any changes in michael's behavior in the
days leading up to the incident yes
what did you see
he was falling apart
he came became completely distraught
um
just
completely distraught not himself
worried
very
just i would describe it as terrified of
of
living in his own home i mean he was
terrified
did you develop
any concerns for yourself when you saw
michael in this condition yes
did that add to the concerns you had for
your safety the safety of your daughter
and the safety of your animals yes
and
who which persons were the source
of your concern
lauren kanrick and robert goodwin
did you have a chance to observe whether
or not
michael barrasson
interacted with lauren canorack or
robert goodwin
alone
in those days leading up to the incident
he never wanted to be alone with them
in fact it was he went out of his way to
not be alone with them
he was terrified of them we were i was
terrified of them
and so
because of all of the postings that were
going on on social media the
the this is non-responsive
it it is somewhat just ask another
question please
all right
that's okay
miss defranco
where were you
uh on the day of the incident
i was at the farm
had you spent the night there yes well
no
no we were at the
bed and breakfast down the street
because my daughter's room was deemed
um
unlivable i guess by the um
fire marshal or whomever the the
building department
so her your daughter's living
arrangement was impacted by what the
town did with respect to the buildings
oh yes she had to leave okay
and did you come back to the farm that
day yes
and uh
did you have
an instance to be sitting in the arena
yes
and was that the indoor arena or the
outdoor indoor arena
okay
where were you sitting
i was sitting in michael's chair so the
door that walks out from the club room
into the indoor arena
there are a bunch of director's chairs
if you were going to the immediate left
of that door the first chair
that's the one i was sitting in and
that's when michael typically sat in
and
um
did who were you sitting with if anyone
nobody i was watching my daughter um she
had finished up riding her horse and
she'd already left and i was just
sitting there
did you encounter michael while you were
sitting in the arena in his chair
yes
did you make any observations of michael
at the time you encountered him while
you were sitting in the arena on the
morning of the incident in his chair yes
he walked out what were your
observations i'm sorry it's okay a
question is better than we get a
question and answer yes sure okay um he
was totally absent catatonic
he didn't even know i was sitting there
did you try to speak with him yes
and did he acknowledge you no
with respect to what you observed that
was happening at the farm
did you develop uh
any understanding as to uh
whether there was some
systematic steps against mike
objection
you're referring to your observations of
michael that day
did he appear normal to you no
did he appear healthy to you no
did you have any concerns about his
safety as a result of your observations
of him that day
absolutely he looked suicidal
i don't have any further questions at
this time
all right cross-examination mr shellhorn
mr franco how many horses did you have
at the property in summer of 2019 i had
one my daughter had two and you said
that your daughter is still competing
yes what is her level that she competes
at
she it competes at intermediary one
is that as an amateur or a professional
or something else professional so your
daughter is a professional uh equestrian
my daughter switched her status from
amateur to professional
when she started working for michael
because those are the rules
and so even though she does not
currently she's not currently employed
in the equestrian community she
maintains her professional status
because that's the level she rides at
so she rides at a high level yes she
does
now you indicated that on august 7th
2019
you were at the
farm or at the barn with your daughter
yes
and you and your daughter were in the
process that day of making arrangements
to leave the farm correct
you indicated that you were looking for
another farm to take your three horses
to yes
and you said that you had
a lot of concerns in those weeks leading
up to august 7th yes
but you hadn't actually made the
arrangements and actually taken the
horses off the property at that point
yet had you no we had an appointment
and that would require you going to meet
with various different
farms or barns yes and you would have to
i think you had said
you were looking for another barn to go
to that was safe and clean yes so you
wanted to make sure that you were
vetting out the place where you were
going to take your horses that it would
be appropriate for them yes as well as
for your daughter
based on her aspirations as a rider
at that point it had nothing to do with
riding or training
we wanted to get the horses off so we
weren't looking for a trainer per se
we were looking for a place for the
horses to be housed
but even in spite of that it did take
effort to try to find a place that would
be appropriate for your horses there are
several places at the area
were you aware
of any of the specific
health conditions related to ms canarac
or mr goodwin's horses
if you i'm sorry just if you're aware
personally or had any awareness of that
no
you didn't ever hear ms kanrak ever make
any physical threats
to whom
well you you indicated myself or to
somebody else
that's a fair question
you indicated earlier you were
interviewed on the day of august 7th
2019. yes you were interviewed by two
detectives detective boasts and detected
midosfelder yes and that was at the barn
yes
and they asked you during the course of
that interview whether you had heard any
physical threats made
to michael barrissone and you said no
and you don't have any personal
knowledge of what happened by the
farmhouse on august 7 2019
i wasn't there
at the on the pattern you didn't see
what happened i wasn't on the patio no
no i wasn't trying to trick you uh no
further questions your honor
all right eddie redirect
uh now redirect your honor all right man
thank you you may step down thank you
record your next witness please
[Music]
steven cautious to the stand please
[Music]
please remain standing for a minute sir
you need to be sworn
place your left hand on that bible
please raise your right hand my court
clerk will administer the oath do you
swear in the presence of almighty god
that the testimony gives to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth i do please station you must by
your last name for the record stephen
the last name is spelled t as in thomas
a-r-s-h-i-s
thank you
mr tarshish
good morning good morning what do you do
for a living i'm an attorney and how
long have you been engaged in the
practice of law
um 35 years
can you give us
your educational background
certainly i went to a city university in
new york attended law school at syracuse
college of law
and graduate school at nyu
what was the graduate degree at nyu uh
it wasn't a degree i went for cost was
in tax okay
um
and uh
when did you first become licensed to
practice law
if you recall
uh
1976 actually and and i'm licensed both
in new york and new jersey it was um
76 in new york and i believe 80 in new
jersey
and with respect to your practice in new
jersey
uh do you have any sort of focus with
respect to your work
um
when i'm asked that question i usually
describe myself as a
business transactional lawyer
but over the last
five or ten years
i've developed a somewhat unique
specialty in equine law
what is equine law if you could briefly
describe that for the jury uh basically
it's providing
the horse community and people involved
in horse businesses whether they be
amateur owners professional riders
breeders trainers
both on the sports side as well as the
racing side have very many of the same
business issues as most businesses
buying and selling horses
importing breeding situations
syndications of of racehorses and sport
horses unfortunately at times sometimes
litigation so because of the
unique nature of the people and the uh
the rules that are associated with the
sport
uh a specialty of i suppose very few
attorneys who do it
has arisen and
i'm one of them
does your has your specialty and your
past experience ever touched upon
the issue of boarding arrangements for
horses and training arrangements for
people oh quite frequently
could you briefly describe your
experience in those areas well
many of the clients i've had are on both
sides i have clients who are operators
of
equestrian boarding facilities
commercial facilities
so they will have come to me they will
come to me i should say
to prepare boarding agreements for the
people who board their horses with them
setting out the rules the terms and
conditions under which
the owner and operator of the equine
boarding facility
will care for and take care of a
person's horses and on the other side of
that
it's the person who has a horse and they
want to
place their horse in the care of an
equine facility so they will ask me to
review frequently a boarding agreement
to make sure it's fair and equitable and
that
their horse is going to be well cared
for and their rights are going to be
protected so
it's like any contract transaction it
will be
on both sides of the of the transaction
in a boarding situation a specialized
form of contract yes very specialized
uh
do you know michael barroso yes i do how
long have you known mr barrison
uh somewhere between 10 and 15 years i
think at this point
and
how did you first come to know mr
barrisson
i first came to know him as a trainer
um
i was training with a
a young woman who was a
whom michael was a mentor if she was a
professional
and she would frequently
for her own benefit take lessons with
michael
and she introduced me to him
and over a period of time
seeing his skill and ability and what he
was able to do and aware of his
reputation i began to take lessons with
him as well so let's take a tangential
turn and topic for a second
um are you also a horseman yes i am okay
and how long have you been pursuing
horse-related uh
activities over 30 years do you consider
yourself to be a hobbyist a professional
something else what do you consider
yourself to be
my time would say i'm a professional the
fact of the matter is i'm an amateur
it's it's something
people who are
involved in the sport in a serious way
uh understands it's a different kind of
sport it's not a hobby it's not like
golf where you play and you put your
clubs in the closet it's a becomes a
matter of a full-time commitment as it
is for me is it a passion for you oh
most definitely
i i ride at least five times a week i
devote at least 15 hours a week
to it i compete
up and down the east coast and i've been
doing it for many many years it might
sound like a naive question but that's
what we're here for to get a full
explanation you ride do you also own
horses yes they do
over the years how many horses have you
owned oh
god well i have both sport horses and
racehorses uh the interest in
racehorsing is a little different it's
it's common for there to be what's known
as fractional ownership in racehorses
unless you're a very big
um very very frankly very very wealthy
or
run the business most racehorses are
owned by
three or four or five people uh sport
horses are usually owned individually
over the years i've probably had
15 or so
horses that i've ridden and competed
with
and probably 10 or so racehorses in
which i've had an interest
and is there a particular area of
horse sports that you focus
at the present time i've i've competed
in the three major disciplines of ending
show jumping and dressage for the last
10 or 12 years it's been dressage
and was it dressage that brought you to
michael yes it was okay
and
what was it about uh michael's
reputation that made you want to train
with him
um
like any teacher
the ability to communicate
to a student is what makes in my view an
exceptional or good teacher and michael
had a very very
uh gifted way of communicating a very
very difficult sport and making it
understandable so that amateurs
such as myself would be able to learn
and progress
he had a gift for community for
communication and a tremendous empathy
for the horses of course
did michael train your horses too no he
did not okay
uh but he trained you correct okay
and your experience with training with
michael did you ever uh
witness him riding horse oh absolutely
sure many times in all the times that
you witnessed uh michael using a horse
riding a horse did you ever see him do
anything harmful to the horse
no absolutely not
michael um
considers his horses gifts from god he
would i think that might have been a
quote even he treated them
as the as most horse people do um very
special and
creatures to be cherished and he was if
anything very very indulgent but never
abusive
so he was your trainer
and was he uh
did you still have a training repardon
did you still have a training
relationship with him in the summer of
2019
not really um
i say that not really because the it was
intermittent normally when you have a
trainer as i do now it's a consistent
relationship where you train with the
certain person
you know on a daily basis uh with
michael it was an occasional clinic or
an occasional lesson so i can't say it
was really you know if i had called it
michael and said i wanted a lesson i
would have had a lesson but i didn't do
it so there was no not a real training
relationship at that point over the
years that you worked with michael and
knew him did you develop a friendship
with them
yes definitely well tell me about your
friendship with michael over those years
um
it was very soon there after we i
started
taking lessons and training with him
uh michael and i
for whatever reasons had a real empathy
with each other we kind of connected
uh both mostly through the love of the
horses
or also to be very candid somewhat
unique in the sport in the sense that
dressage particularly is a sport
dominated by women
i know for a fact uh
that 90 of the members of the united
states dressage federation are women
so men don't usually participate in the
sport
so
you know that was
kind of withdraw each other to because
we were kind of you know oddballs in the
sport and even though he was a
a
you know
tremendous successful you know
international reputation professional
and i was a
lousy amateur you know that kind of
brought us together and we just liked
each other and got along and enjoyed
each other's company
did you socialize with them oh yeah did
you socialize with them at the farm in
long valley yes
um
did there ever come a time
when he became your client for purposes
of legal services yes they did
okay and
uh when did he first become your client
for legal services if you recall i'm not
asking you to tell us anything about the
specifics of this over 10 years ago but
i couldn't
i'd have to go look at my files and and
see when you know the first matter might
have been but it's
i'm sure 10 years ago at least
so over that decade
how would you describe your professional
relationship as his attorney was it
intermittent constant something else
well the work would be intermittent
because it's not the nature of something
that comes up every day
but
in my mind
i believed he considered me his attorney
whenever a legal matter of
was
anytime the services of an attorney were
needed he always called me but it could
be three or four months could pass or
two weeks could pass or six months could
pass there was no consistency to it it
was when they need a rose
um so but i i
i'd like to think i certainly did think
that he thought of me as his attorney
well let's move specifically to the time
period of july 2019 actually let's start
it in june
through the day of the incident you're
aware that an incident occurred on
august 7 2019 yes i am right so
from june of that year to the date of
the incident
uh
did michael contact you uh requesting
your services yes he did
and was it uh
a matter you had previously consulted
with him on or something new something
new
without uh
revealing any client conferences
confidences
what was the subject matter of that
engagement
he called me to tell me that he had
a client um
uh i'm going to object
that it's here it's not just it's not
going right let's not get into the
specifics of what was said
i understand so the question would be to
describe what the matter was but without
using someone's words i understand of
course i do
um the purpose for which he called me
was
um
that he
um
he had a problem with a particular
a border we wanted to leave the farm
and uh the person would not leave
that's as simply as i could put it it
was much more complicated than that but
that's about as simply as i could state
it did michael identify to you that
border
by name you mean yes yes and who was it
the lauren canary
following the time when michael
called you
to engage you on this new matter
uh
did you come to the farm
yes
do you recall coming to the farm in late
july of 2019.
i was at the farm several times and
certainly in late july okay
do you recall
having uh
conversations with michael
about the matter that you were
representing him on with respect to
lauren canara yes i did
did any of those conversations
uh
occur
in public areas such as well let's
specifically did any of those
conversations take place in the locker
area of the barn
i don't
recall any taking place there there were
so many conversations
i know where the vast majority of the
conversations i could save with certain
took place but i don't have a specific
recollection of anything in the locker
area
um are you personally familiar with the
locker area yes i am let me show you a
photograph that was moved in evidence
says 800-42
let me know when you've had a chance to
read i know i know it very well
does that photograph accurately depict
how the locker area looked when you were
on the farm in uh the late july early
august time period of 2019. yes it does
uh is there a bench in that area
no and there was no bench there
now you said you could recall where
certain conversations took place did you
say the vast majority
correct
and
what's your recollection as to where the
vast majority of your conversations with
michael took place it was an area that
was referred to as the lounge area
and uh
where was the lounge area located
it was the center of the of of the um of
the farm or the building
with the comprise the stables and the
barn
was the lounge area
uh
the club room uh it was the club room i
can
tell you that
this this staircase here
if you walked up this staircase there
was a door here and if you walk through
that door you entered into the lounge
area the lounge area was when you came
to the front
of the entrance to to the farm there
were double doors and if you open the
double doors there's a very very very
large room that was the lounge area in
that area was a kitchen area
and then there was a huge pool table and
in the center of the area
was um couches and
seats the reason it was there was
because there was a
a glass wall
and which was not unusual for a lot of
um horse facilities the idea was that
clients and friends could sit in the
lounge area look through the glass and
watch
you know their kids their husbands their
mothers their daughters watched them
ride so that was the that was
pretty obviously the purpose of the
lounge area and that's where because it
was the largest area at the farm and
very comfortable obviously with couches
and chairs in a kitchen where people
would congregate and that's where the
vast majority of my conversation with
michael took place
was warren canorack ever present in the
room when you had conversations of that
nature with michael barrison no
absolutely not
did there come a time
in late july or august preceding the
incident
that you became concerned that your
private conversations with michael
barrasson were somehow being overheard
by lauren cataract yes excuse me yes
what happened that gave me that concern
well
unfortunately
this had dragged on the whole incident
and getting worse and worse almost by
the day
and given the very very almost his but
the incestuous nature of the horse world
what was going on at the farm became
common knowledge within the horse
community so there's a tremendous amount
of social media
being posted about this stuff and i
believe
i heard it from so many different
sources but i believe i first became
aware
that she was claiming to have heard
conversations i believe i first became
aware of it through postings on social
media
was robert goodwin ever in the room when
you were having private conversations
with michael about the matter no i've
never met bob robert goodwin never seen
him
did you ever see any social media
postings
um
with respect to what was going on at the
farm oh god yes
uh prior to the incident yes
uh how did you obtain access to those
postings well i'm not a social media
person
but they would be pointed out to me by
michael
and uh mary haskins gray
uh justin uh harden might have done it
you know a lot of this i don't remember
specifically the source after you know
it was such a chaotic time and so much
was going on so i can't necessarily pin
down where it might have heard something
i just know i heard it and these are the
likely places that i from whom i would
have heard it
with respect and then i would go look
and see for myself yeah
so with respect to the postings that you
saw
did you see any that reflected words
that you had spoken in private to
michael yes
how many such postings did you see i can
only
one
particularly stands out because i was so
stunned
it was
really disturbing because it was like
you know it's like somebody was in the
room like she was in the room
and i and it was very it was very it
the only way she could have known it
somehow by hearing it because it was
such a narrow specific conversation it
wouldn't have been something that would
have been passed along
to other people in idle gossip and
conversation
so you used the pronoun she in that
description to whom are you lauren
kenner i'm sorry
lauren kanras
did their comment
have lauren
robert goodman and her horses leave
michael barrasson's farm yes
and did you make any
uh arrangements for
lauren cataract and her horses to go to
another barn yes i did
what arrangements did you make
um
i understand i never spoke to a long
counteract
and i had never met carl and father
until actually something occurred
recently
but i never saw her didn't know her
i only spoke with her father jonathan
canorack and he and i had
well without getting into the spoken
words i'm asking you what arrangements
well i'll tell you he and i spoke about
um negotiated negotiate an arrangement
whereby she would voluntarily
leave the farm so that other
judicial means to have a remove would
not be necessary and that's what we
talked ab a negotiation of those terms
so that she would leave
did you identify a specific farm where
she could go yes i did
was there a specific trainer involved
with that farm yes there was was that
trainer
uh
in some manner
equal to the level of training that
michael could offer yeah objection
what's the basis for the objection
i don't think there's a there there's a
foundation for that question judge
it also calls for his opinion and i'm
not sure what the relevance of that
opinion would be here
yeah i'm not sure what the relevance of
his opinion is
but certainly the arrangements that he
made is something you can get into
okay
so uh
that trainer
was it an olympic level trainer
um had won a gold medal at the pan
american games
equal to an olympic rider yes and did
that trainer have a facility uh with us
similar to michael's
absolutely equal to
and it was approximately 15 to 20
minutes from the long valley location
where
michael's farm was and that trainer have
stalls available for lauren canorax
horses yes
and
uh
did you communicate that information to
jonathan canorac yes i did and i
communicated the individual's name who
was known to both lauren and her father
following the time when you communicated
that to jonathan kenorak
did you have an understanding as to
whether or not there was an agreement
that lauren and her horses were going to
leave michael's farm objection
let me see that sidebar please
the objection sustained rephrase your
question council
it's a narrow question
i don't remember the question
yeah he's going to he's going to
rephrase the question
go ahead council
in your negotiations with jonathan
canorack
what was your perception of his role in
those negotiations
being a lawyer and having to answer
these questions sometimes is a challenge
because i'm kind of monitoring myself
right
his role was
to speak on our behalf
to find a place
that she found acceptable
based upon her own standards her own
requirements where she therefore would
voluntarily leave michael's farm and go
to
another location
and his role was to negotiate the terms
that would be acceptable to her
did she leave the farm no she did not
did there come a time
after those negotiations occurred
that you wrote a letter
uh
providing some sort of notice to lauren
cataract
well um i'm confused because you're
leaving out of peace
um
we negotiated an understanding
i believed uh my me i believe we had an
agreement
election judgment well it's his it's his
understanding that was the basis for the
last objection that we addressed at
sidewalk i know but that that's
i'll allow that it's it's his
understanding based on his interaction
so it's it's
sufficient
without anything more it was his
understanding there was an agreement
what's your next question
i'd like to show you what's been marked
for identification as defense exhibit
700-3
why don't you take a moment and look at
that
okay
so
okay yeah
okay
you've reviewed exhibit 700-3 yes yes i
have
uh
without
do you recognize what that is yes i do
all right is that a letter you drafted
yes it is and was there a date on the
letter that you drafted august 5th
go ahead ask your next question this
particular copy i've shown you is
unsigned
do you agree
yes it is did you cause a signed copy of
this letter to be delivered to lauren
kanarek and john goodman absolutely
robin goodwin
robert
um no to jonathan canary and to lauren
canary
not the robert goodwin okay
uh in and and
did you
give lauren canorack notice that she
needed to vacate the form
that's what was the purpose of the
letter yes
remove 700-3 in evidence
i would object judge there's been
testimony about it it's hearsay
but the objection sustained but
questions counselor you can ask
questions about the content of the
letter
can you tell me
specifically
from your own recollection
the dates
or dates when you were having these
negotiations with jonathan canorack
it would have
been the
friday preceding this
which i guess would have been the second
i suppose
yeah and the week
at least the week before that and maybe
even the week prior to that it went on
for some time
so when you say the second you're
referring to august 2nd 2019 yes and
you're saying that it was occurring on
that date as well as potentially the
week before yeah i mean the specific
dates of course are days i can't
remember but i know we had several
conversations and it took quite a bit of
back and forth
to get to the point where i thought we
were on the friday preceding this letter
and
do you recall giving
canorack a specific
uh date and time by which you were
demanding on behalf of michael barrasson
that she vacate the premises yes i do
and what's your recollection august 7th
wednesday august 7th
and
did you cause this letter to be
delivered to warren cataract i think i
asked that but if you could just say
again yes i did and on what date did you
call it to be delivered to her
um
i can't recall i can only assume it was
the day that uh it was delivered by
email so it would have been delivered
the date it was it's dated august 5th
august 5th is the date correct okay
uh was michael aware that you were
sending this letter oh yeah
did michael express to you any concerns
about sending this letter yes he did
what concerns did he express to you he
didn't think she would leave
he'd
subsequent to
the delivery of that letter
did you
proceed
with any
actions toward
legal proceedings against
lauren canorack and rob goodwin to have
them vacate the farm
yes they did and i have to confess at
this point my memory is a little fuzzy i
did what i said i was going to do and i
initiated an eviction proceeding which
um
uh and she was served with
a complaint in eviction
let me
show you what i've marked for
identification as document 700-5
could you review that for yourself
yeah
now
oh there's no question i'm just asking
you to review it
okay yes
so uh you've reviewed exhibit 705
correct yes let me show you what i've
marked for identification as exhibit 704
please review that and let me know when
you're ready i know when i'm ready i'm
ready you're ready now yes okay
um
what is exhibit 704
this is an affidavit of service
uh of the um eviction complaint
uh on lauren canary what is exhibit 705
the verified complaint
uh
uh
which was served
pursuant as reflected by this affidavit
of service
do you have a refreshed recollection as
to the precise date when the eviction
complaint was served on lauren cataract
um
yes or no yes what's your refreshed
recollection august 6th
hey
thank you i'll take these
in connection with uh spending time with
michael in the time period from july
31st through august 6th
did you notice
any changes in his affect
well the change i noticed preceded those
days but certainly
be very much so in those days yes let's
move it back further then let's take it
from july 15th forward were you were you
uh in michael's presence in july of
2019. yes i was
did you notice changes in his affect as
it got closer to the date of the
incident absolutely
excuse me absolutely
what were your observations
he became
very very upset
almost to the point of um being unable
to function
as an attorney and this was my client
it got so bad i couldn't even have a
conversation with him he was um
in constant fear
of so many things and all he would talk
about he was in a loop
all he would do was talk about the fears
that he had
and and here i am trying to be a lawyer
to a situation and proposing
solutions or possible paths to take and
he wouldn't deal with him he it was
difficult to have a conversation with
him he was constantly agitated
um
at times he was incoherent
it got so bad that i threatened to quit
i said i'm not serving any purpose
you're not listening to me you're not
hearing me
um
i i remember having you know screaming
at him i scream at him not him yelling
at me because i was so upset that he was
just ignoring me i don't think i
realized at the time
you know how out of it he was uh and it
only perhaps was later as we got really
close to the sixth and seventh when he
became just
you know non-functioning just completely
you could couldn't function
did the fears
relate to lauren cataract totally too
long camera
he was afraid that
um aside from her
sustained
based upon your uh
professional relationship with michael
uh did you have uh an understanding as
to uh his finances
oh yes
uh
and did you have an understanding as to
michael's network
um
i had a a pretty good idea i don't think
i would say i had a you know
a really um exact or precise
understanding but i knew he was very
very unique
in the horse world how is he unique in
the horse world
um again bearing in mind and it's hard
if you're not part of this community
this is an incestuous community where
everybody knows everything
and michael was unique that he was
successful businessman
i mean they're with all due respect to
their professional accomplishments
they're olympic writers who don't have a
nickel to their name they rely on
sponsors
to support them michael had accumulated
wealth in the millions
and it's just not done he was a very he
was a brilliant businessman
i have no further questions at this time
what
close examination
mr tarshish do you have any awareness of
what michael barrasson's monthly
expenses were no
do you know anything about how much it
cost them to run the two farms they own
no or pay payroll no
take care of the horses no
now you were asked a question by mr uh
diminger
about being contacted by mr barrissone
with respect to the issue with ms
canorack correct
do you remember when you were first
contacted about that
precisely no i don't the best i could
tell you
it was
either late june the early part of july
because my reaction was
when he spoke to me he had told me of a
situation that had been gone ongoing for
months
and my reaction was why didn't you call
me sooner so i think it was late june or
early july so you think he contacted you
somewhere
a month to six weeks potentially before
the shooting could be yeah
do you have records of that
no
you were his lawyer
yes
and this was ongoing you had been
representing him for approximately 10
years or so at that point on and off yes
and he contacted you about a issue that
he had with this border and wanted to
take action
yes
you weren't aware of any specific
written contracts that mr barristone had
with ms canorack related to their
business arrangements i was aware there
was no written contract
now if i could just ask you
uh judge may i approach yes
[Music]
mr tarshish i'm just showing you again
what's been marked as 705 and 704
and i'm just trying to get the the
timeline right sure
704
is an affidavit of service
correct and does that indicate that it
was served on august 6 2019 at 11 53 a.m
yes it does who fills this out
uh the person who's whose signature
appears the person who actually served
the document upon miss cataract
and is that based on something that you
would have given to that person or that
company to serve
i would have given them the complaint to
serve they would have served it and then
as a consequence of them serving it they
generate from by themselves this
document it's not a it's not a form that
i give them and they fill in they
they use their form and provide it to me
okay so if it says here that the papers
that were served on that day and time
was a letter
i guess you're saying that would be
wrong
uh i don't recall um
this complaint was never filed
oh it was never filed
that's right okay
so you sent a copy of the verified
complaint
unfiled
to ms canorack
they'll stop you i'm sure
michael did not want to start eviction
he wanted to scare her into leaving
so we suggested
serving her with the papers but not
filing them hoping
this alone would give her the impetus to
honor the agreement we thought we had
i understand so that that was my going
to be my follow-up question was that mr
dynger showed you
705. yeah there's nothing even filled
out on this thing
that's what i wanted to ask you right so
okay so this is a complaint that's not
filed correct
i understand and the purpose of sending
it was for michael barissone to scare
lauren canorack into thinking that he
was serious or something for that effect
exactly
no further questions judge
all right you may step down sir thank
you can i redirect i'm sorry all right
you may step down mr tortious thank you
what do you have another witness counsel
can i check that
sure
[Music]
good for you
joe williams
joe williams
hi mr williams come on up to the witness
stand just remain standing place your
left hand on the bible if you would
raise your right hand my clerk will
administer a note because the jurors ask
if you could fix that thing
do you swear in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony gives to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth yes ma'am please state your
name and spell your last name for the
record joseph williams w-i-l-l-i
ams thank you
have a seat mr williams please keep your
voice up nice and loud that microphone
does not project your voice and only
records yes sir if you don't understand
a question please indicate that and i
will have counsel rephrase yes sir all
right go ahead mr williams has been
sworn
mr williams my name is chris dininger
um
what do you what is your profession
currently i am
a barefoot horse trimmer and i train
horses young horses and behavioral
issues
and uh do you operate that business in
new jersey yes sir
uh what
town i travel okay
um and do you also live in new jersey
yes sir great
um
have you always worked in a horse
related field no so
uh well what have you spent your time
doing over your career
i am retired uh detective sergeant from
township of berkeley heights
so a police officer yes sir detective
sergeant detective sergeant how many
years did you serve in law enforcement
uh 25 years
uh what type of work did you do in law
enforcement as a detective sergeant
we handled everything from
a bad check to
you know
every kind of case possibly
burglaries car thefts a little bit of
everything
drugs yes sir
contraband
yes sir
and do you recall what year it was that
you retired from the police force sure
do
february 1st of uh 19.
february 1st 2019
now mr williams
um
what did you ever perform services as a
farrier
i was a failure
trained as a farrier but i took my
business all barefoot okay
um did you ever uh well do you know
michael barroso yes sir
and in what capacity do you know he was
a client i i was kind of he was a client
of mine for approximately five to six
months
okay and when was that client
relationship with him
um approximately
february of 19 to
august july or august of 19th
was michael aware of your service in law
enforcement yes he was
did there come a time
in
late july
of 2019 that michael called you
yes sir
and
i don't want you to talk about the words
that were spoken in the phone
conversation
but what was your understanding as to
why he was calling you
your personal understanding as opposed
to what was spoken
understanding was he called me in
reference to
having a problem with
a client who also resided on the
property
and about
the situation between him her and her
boyfriend
did michael ask you for any advice with
respect to the situation
yes he did
based upon
your communications with michael in that
phone conversation
did you have any concerns
about what was happening at the farm
i don't know if i had concerns i gave my
input on what i would do
what input did you give him
i advised him to um go down to the
municipal court and file a harassment
complaint i told him the ground to the
uh they're going to have them fill out a
probable cause statement given the facts
and see if there's enough justification
to
you know file a charge and i told him to
you know
retain an attorney not for that but as
far as him advising me he had problems
with
evicting her from the property
did you communicate to him anything
about
the risk of
someone putting something in the vehicle
yes and in reference to
um harassment complaint i also told them
you know if you're harassing her she's
going to do the same thing
in reference to
the vehicle
i advised him after he advised me that
he thought she was on some sort of
narcotic i told him to keep his vehicles
locked
in in the event that you know something
could possibly potentially be
placed inside the vehicle to kind of set
him up
no further questions
false examination
am i being disrespectful if i call you
mister now that you're retired you can
call me whatever you want sir
just don't call me late for dinner
mr williams so so when michael barason
contacted you
so your advice was that he should go to
the municipal court and file a
harassment complaint yes sir
you also told him
generally walked him through the process
he could do to follow that yes sir
but you also told him that it was
possible that someone who was using
drugs may plant drugs in his car
potentially being due to the fact that
he was having uh
problems with this person
and he you know
he advised me that he thought or i don't
recall exactly the conversation but she
potentially could be using drugs so i
just told him to keep his vehicles
locked
but you would agree with me that someone
who's addicted to drugs
doesn't just go give up their drugs and
stick it in someone else's car to plant
it on them and get them in trouble i'm
not do i never done a drug in my life
i'm not a drug user but it makes sense
and fair to say berkeley heights the the
drug problem there
is not at epic proportions the way it is
in other places
we had our fair share but yes did you
have cases where people who were
addicted to drugs were planting drugs in
other people's cars i've had cases where
drugs were
put placed in someone's car
no further questions judge what
you may step down thank you sir
this would be a good time to start yeah
you want a break now yeah all right
we'll take our lunch break a little bit
early 12
15 but we'll resume around 115 or 120
somewhere around there thank you
you